what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
so historically speaking I don't really
split stories at least not recently I
don't I mean there was a time that I did
but I've basically kind of just gone to
doing you know all the the whole story
arc for the most part but with Superman
or I guess with Action Comics revenge
I wanted to split this in half and the
reason why is because the second half of
this discussion is not something I'd be
able to do if we do the entire thing at
once and we'll get to why you know here
in a minute but if you're just catching
up in the first part of revenge we had
basically run over the idea that General
Zod had basically been taken he'd been
freed from the Phantom Zone and had been
taken by the Suicide Squad for the
purpose of being inducted onto their
team the result is that he basically
engineered his own escape and then he
was met with the arrival of Eradicator
and cyborg superman who recruited him to
their cause of course their cause
basically being the defeat of Superman I
mean it's pretty par for the course so
the idea was to bring Superman down
using some of his most notable foes now
remember all of this basically stemmed
out of Superman reborn when mr. Mixel
pedelec had warped reality one of the
things that happened was that in
addition to Superman basically being
restored to his classic self we also
ended up having hank henshaw his
memories restored meaning that he
realized that he was cyborg Superman and
this is important because what this
means is that despite all these
individuals being here cyborg Superman
was the only one who originally knew of
the entire history before the new 52 it
wasn't until he basically started going
around and waking up people like [ __ ]
to their true history do they began to
become aware of what it was that was
going on now the reason why this is also
kind of cool is because this coincides
with their intention to attack the
fortress of solitude and the reason for
this is because the fortress of solitude
is by definition the last bastion of
Krypton it's all the technology and
different resources and so on that
Superman's been able to accrue over the
course of his career and by various
technologies that he had at his disposal
when he first landed on earth but he was
able to basically go through and create
the fortress of solitude but this
matters because cyborg superman and
General Zod and others want to get their
hands on the technology inside the
fortress of solitude for a variety of
different reasons now these reasons
aren't absolute I mean they basically
range in a multitude of different ways
for example General Zod wants to
recreate Krypton and the fortress of
solitude
she locked within will let him do that
with the defeat of Superman it would
allow Blanc to basically go through uses
telepathy and telekinesis and just start
this canvass of death as its described
these are the kind of things that end up
popping up with all their grand schemes
so it's really just an amalgamation of
personal desires that come together for
the purpose of taking down Superman now
the other half of this is that in the
event when the I guess the original
black vault in the Suicide Squad was
destroyed in the ensuing chaos
Superman lost his eyesight and so at
this moment right now Superman's
effectively blind now again you can get
caught up with a little more of an
explanation in the video down in the
description which was part 1 but this is
a scenario that Superman has not readily
faced before the idea of losing his
eyesight and the way this is done is
actually kind of cool when it comes to
his various abilities that requires
sight so his telescopic vision x-ray
vision so on and so forth those are gone
with heat vision he still has that and
the reason is at least as its explained
is because heat vision is not a function
of eyesight heat vision is a function of
just channeling energy through his eyes
it's really one of the cool things in
order for Superman to still be somewhat
effective the other half of this is
remember in the last video we had talked
about how the assault on Superman from
his various foes was being broadcast on
live television now this is kind of a
repeat of history remember back when the
original Death of Superman story when
doomsday had first popped up he had
basically gone through and the fight
between himself and Superman was
broadcast to the world and so it's
almost like DC is basically kind of
going back and learning from that story
and correcting things the reason why I
say that is because while members of the
superhero community for the most part
did what they could at the end of the
day doomsday was just too much the death
of Superman was designed to be a story
where Superman was the only guy who
could beat doomsday and sacrificed his
life in the process with this it's not
the same way we now have the Superman
family Lex Luthor Superman Chinese
Superman Supergirl and we have
superwoman we also have Krypto the
Superdog which is kind of cool but we
have these various characters who all
have the ability to stand toe-to-toe
alongside Superman as he faces off
against his own other enemies something
else to point out here and this is
actually a brilliant maneuver when it
comes to DC rebirth one of the things
that DC's focused on is the cohesiveness
of the
DC universe which is to say superheroes
crossing over into stories that you
wouldn't normally see in this particular
story we don't see Batman we don't see
Green Lantern the flash Wonder Woman or
any of the members of the Justice League
we don't see like Shazam or anything
like that but it's hinted at the idea
that Superman should call them in and
that's one of the great things about
this the introduction of the Superman
family into this story is the idea that
on the whole one of the biggest issues
that Superman has historically had when
it came to his own stories is that it
was always just him against the world no
matter how bad things got it was always
Superman somehow musters up the courage
to win the fight and if you're a
Superman fan you absolutely love it but
if you're a person coming into county
books with an eye for practicality it
doesn't make any sense to you there has
to be a point where Superman just can't
do it on his own and that's the cool
thing here is because this brings that
question into the equation Lois Lane
asks shouldn't you call him the Justice
League you're literally blind and you're
going against some of your most powerful
villains Superman's response is maybe we
should but at that moment the forces of
General Zod and everybody basically
launched their attack
Superman faces off against them the best
they can but when it comes to the
introduction of the members of the
Justice League it's not necessary
because the Superman family responds but
it's those little things that make DC
rebirth so cohesive it's those small
things that make the story so unique
because if this were going to be a story
from like the 1990s or the 1980s well
then somehow Superman would get his
eyesight by magic and then somehow he
would end up winning the day and that
would be it and it would take away from
the gravity of the situation because
with the Superman family coming in we as
the reader look at this and we're like
well then Superman can't do it on his
own if Superman would have fight them by
himself he would probably die the super
family stepping in and helping him out
shows the gravity of that situation and
that's why it's so cool now the other
half of this is Lois Lane and Jonathan
Kent remember they're residing within
the fortress of solitude that is kind of
trying to keep hidden as best they can I
mean they're out in the middle of
nowhere I mean even if they were to get
out of the fortress of solitude they're
still in the middle of the Arctic so I
mean they can't just like jump on a
plane and fly away and even if they
tried the Superman legion of Doom's so
to speak they would destroy Lois Lane
and Jonathan so what is up happening
here is it basically has Superman and
the Superman family fighting against
these various individuals but the cool
thing about this and notice this General
Zod
the one who leaves the conflict by no
definition is generals on the leader of
the group but General Zod is a much
better tactician than Hank Henshaw
cyborg Superman as the what he ends up
doing is he actually reaches out to the
character of blank this super powerful
telepath and telekinetic and simply says
link my mind to everybody else's I've
seen how Superman fights I know what
he's capable of I know how to defeat him
and the other members of the Superman
family but we have to do it in a way
that works effectively and so each
member is paired off strategically with
those individuals they're best suited to
fight against going to this massive
battle and you have Eradicator facing
off against against superwoman
Eradicator is a being of energy
superwoman is a being of energy you know
you have blank going against Chinese
hitman going against Kenan Kong and it's
kind of these cool little moments
because Keenan's never faced blank he
doesn't know who he is
blank as an older guy just kind of
haunted off of well hey you know I
couldn't survive one of your punches
don't hit me only for you know Kenan to
basically be taken by surprise with
blanks telepathy and telekinesis
but with Supergirl it's an interesting
situation because remember when it came
to the character of heroes or L that
before crisis on Infinite Earths she was
more powerful than Superman was she was
stronger she was faster she was more
capable there wasn't necessarily a
definitive answer given to that at least
not that I'm aware and the declaration
of her be more powerful than Superman
really came by way of crisis on Infinite
Earths it was that 12-issue story and it
wasn't until you know the final conflict
against the anti-monitor
that we actually learned that when she
basically died but in the post-crisis on
Infinite Earths landscape while she
didn't appear for some 20 years or I
guess maybe even ten years after the
event took place when she came back it
was still this idea that she could be
more powerful than Superman was now the
pre-crisis Supergirl is a thing we
haven't seen for a long time
Supergirl as she showed up after crisis
on Infinite Earths has routinely been
shown as either equal to Superman in
power or less powerful but this story
begins to hint at the idea that she may
be more capable than he is because she
goes toe-to-toe against cyborg superman
and that's not an easy feat remember
cyborg is the most powerful of all the
versions of these characters that exist
right now but at the end of the day none
of it really seems to matter because of
the fact that General Zod and the
villains managed to get their hands on
the Phantom Zone projector and now
remember the Phantom Zone projector is
basically another
means of transporting people to the
Phantom Zone it exists for the purpose
it's like this portable device of just
teleporting them away once the Superman
family shows up with the intention of
trying to continue this fight General
Zod grabs a projector and just teleports
them into the Phantom Zone
and again it's kind of a cool moment
because what this does is begin setting
the stage for their possibility that mr.
Oz is effectively Superman now the way
this initially picks up is with Superman
actually gaining his eyesight back now
we're not really given a definitive
explanation for why this is we're just
kind of told to accept it that that's
just the way it is but what isn't
happening here is of course with a
couple other people transported
alongside Superman in the form of
Eradicator and cyborg the remaining
battle outside really sees General Zod
taking out Mongol intended to take out
Supergirl but then we also end up having
Jonathan Kent dawn this Kryptonian
battle suit now again this Kryptonian
battle suit was the suit that was used
by Superman - previously heal himself
the problem with this is that his
injuries were so extreme it effectively
burned out the healing capabilities of
the battle suit which is the reason why
they didn't use it to give his eyesight
back but the suit is designed for
conflict and it's designed to face off
against powerful Kryptonians with
Jonathan Kent at the helm of this thing
he's able to face off against General
Zod but in the middle of all this he
begins to sort of panic he begins to
worry and a disembodied voice mr. Oz
begins to chime in basically telling him
you're not alone I will guide you I'm
very familiar with this suit everything
will be okay and it's these small things
these small little tidbits that begin to
hint at the idea of who mr. Oz is now we
won't definitively know until we get to
like Doomsday Clock in that whole
gravely Q story off but it's the small
things that are being said the armor
will protect you until help arrives I
know how this armor works you know the
idea that mr. Oz is looking out for
Jonathan Kent and looking out for
Superman and so what this does is it
brings in the nature of this theory now
this is not a theory that I thought up
although I kind of wish I had this is a
theory that was actually thrown onto the
DC Comics subreddit by a guy named
Martin passes least I think that's
that's that's how you do it but how you
pronounce it but the linkle be down in
the description so you can go check it
out but it's actually really cool
because the theory of Martin Casas is
that mr. oz is Superman the
he's a Superman that you've never heard
of if you have heard of him through one
of the very few that hath 99.99999% of
people have never heard of this version
of Superman this is the original
Superman contrary to what you might
think where the Superman that were
reading about right now debuted in
Action Comics number one in 1938 that's
not the first Superman the very first
Superman was actually a guy named Bill
Dunn I think his name was and he was
given his powers by a guy named Ernst
who was basically just this crazy you
know mad scientist earth hurts Molly I
think his name was
but this story was in a five issue run
that was created by Jerry Siegel and Joe
Shuster back when they were in high
school that was called science fiction
the advance guard a future civilization
now the idea here was that Bill Dunn was
basically given powers of telepathy but
the powers were temporary they were
designed to be that way because Ernst
wanted to be able to test his formula on
someone to see whether or not it would
actually work now of course this led to
you know Bill Dunn being a bad guy and
trying to take over the world but
because the powers were temporary he
effectively lost them but noticed this
the powers of Bill Dunn included
telepathy they included things like
cosmic awareness knowing everything
that's going on the powers of Bill Dunn
included the ability to basically work
with other people or manipulate other
people now it's entirely possible that
this is not true but remember where the
character of this original Superman DC's
got virtually a blank slate I mean they
can do anything they want to with this
guy but the original Superman was bald
you know he was a white guy he fits all
the characteristics of mr. Oz mr. Oz
saying things like I'm familiar with
this suit I'm familiar with Kryptonians
I know what Superman are about I know
everything about you guys it fits in now
some of it may also be wishful thinking
right now I mean it may be like a lot of
comic fans do or we just kind of
rearrange the pieces to make them fit
the way we want to but again I'm kind of
curious what you're all saut is about
him being a version of Superman or at
least the original very first Superman
of course is also asked the question
where did he come from how did he come
back has he been there the entire time
because remember mr. Oz knows everything
about Superman everything about his life
before the new 52 presumably before
crisis on Infinite Earths mr. Oz knows
at all jumping back to this story and
dealing with the idea of the Phantom
Zone we ultimately end up dealing with
Superman coming to the realization that
Ursa is
actually alive now this is kind of an
interesting scenario because what this
does is it feeds on the concept of
Superman last Sun to a degree for those
of you guys who are not familiar ursa is
the wife of General Zod and the mother
of lore Zod but here's the biggest issue
here DC seems to be grabbing the
character of lure Zod the son of General
Zod and then just kind of rebooting him
and the reason why I say that is because
Lourdes lures odds really big moment
really kind of like the introduction to
his character in DC Comics came with
Superman last son a story that was
written by Geoff Johns and the idea here
was that at some point a kid just
crash-landed in Metropolis and Superman
basically adopted this kid named him
Christopher and this kid effectively had
all the powers of a Kryptonian now this
of course led to the return of General
Zod you know the character of ursa so on
and so forth the idea that they were
basically trying to re-establish you
know Krypton more or less and eventually
it led to lor Zod becoming a good guy
and then actually turned coding against
his parents and flying back into the
Phantom Zone in order to close the
portal and you know contain General Zod
and his forces once again
but while Christopher did return while
Laura Zod did end up coming back
effectively he was a good guy he rebuked
the entire history of his parents in
this scenario it does not seem to play
out the same way instead what seems to
basically happen here much like what had
happened in the original Superman the
last Sun storyline Laura Zod was born
from Ursa and General Zod while they
were in the Phantom Zone the difference
here is that he never escaped he never
came back he's just always been there
and so the idea here is that he
alongside his mother are basically the
reason why general Zod's done everything
that he's been doing
we're basically told that from the time
General Zod first popped out in Suicide
Squad rebirth his singular goal has
always been to get his family back he
doesn't care about the armies of Krypton
he doesn't care about all those lost
souls that are out there in the Phantom
Zone all he wants is to get his family
back and it's one of the coolest things
because it humanizes his character like
Superman has his family he's gotten Lois
Lane he's got Jonathan Kent General Zod
is not that far off they're basically
like a mirror image of Superman as we
know him and so it's really kind of like
this cool moment where these characters
stand side by side for represent two
starkly different things now of course
once we end up finding out that this was
the motivation behind General Zod
ultimately we end up having this Phantom
Zone projector opened once again that
allows super
and to grab Eradicator and ultimately
Eradicator escapes alongside General Zod
but what is up taking place is that the
rest of the Superman family end up
closing off the Phantom Zone with cyborg
superman trapped inside now this does
not mean he dies it doesn't mean that
he's gone what this is DC doing is
actually putting him on the back burner
at some point along the line he could
escape the Phantom Zone
and suddenly cyborg Superman's back one
of the worst things that a comic book
publisher can do is kill a superhero or
super villain and the reason why is
because of the fact that while comic
books do have a measure of suspension of
disbelief there also has to be some
measure of propriety some measure of
continuity that comes into play with
individual characters a really good
point is the character of Colossus
Colossus died in the 1990s when he
basically sacrificed his life to cure
the legacy virus this virus just racking
up a death toll of millions of lives but
the fact that Colossus came back during
Joss Whedon's astonishing x-men
basically cheapen the fact that he had
died in the first place it was the same
thing with Superman himself Superman
sacrificed his life to save the world in
a battle against doomsday and then
suddenly while he was just in a
Kryptonian healing matrix it cheapens
his death it takes away from how
significant that death was and what
seems to be going on here is DC is
effectively kind of shying away from
this idea of just killing off
supervillains left and right and instead
throwing them into someplace where they
can't escape on their own and somebody
will let them out later on down the line
whether they mean to or whether it's
accidental so it's a pretty intelligent
way of going through and figuring out a
way to deal with cyber war Superman but
again the real big talk about this whole
video is the nature the character of mr.
Oz mr. Oz going through and racking up
these various superheroes putting them
in stasis keeping them hidden if that's
the question of who he is now my money
is still on the fact that this is
classic Lex Luthor that's my money here
the fact that he says well I know how
this suit works that's not specific to
the original Superman anybody who
encountered it anybody who ever piloted
it anybody intelligent enough to figure
out how it works but it does raise the
question with all the histories that are
out there of these individual characters
that people are speculating for the
identity of mr. Oz is it possible to
navigate those waters and to juggle
those blocks around and to sort of shift
things up in a way to make them fit this
mold or is it easier to just take a
character that virtually no one
ever heard of bring him back make him a
clean slave and then introduce him as
somebody else we don't have the answer
to that question we don't really know
what's going on at this point is simply
just a theory on who he is but what this
story ends up doing is it actually ends
up basically bringing to fruition the
idea that General Zod is going to try to
raise his own monarchy so to speak that
the age of General Zod has begun when
he's standing alongside his wife his son
as well as the Eradicator with the
intention of trying to restore Krypton
effectively bringing back this new
Krypton story long war or less from
before the new 52 but you know again if
it's really a cool story it's pretty
interesting in terms of how all this
unfolds and how it all comes together
but I'm curious let me know if you think
you know what you think about that
theory down in the comment section and
make sure you guys check out that guy's
reddit post because it's something like
two weeks old it's really not that old
it's still pretty new and at this point
it's really the most popular theory on
reddit with regards to who mr. Oz's
identity is but anyway guys we're gonna
go ahead and bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comment explain
and make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the Rob port
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and yeah I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]